a bloody election strategy that is the
focus of tonight's angle
all right the Memo's gone out from the
DNC and from the Biden puppeteers now
these sick individuals think that a mass
shooting at a shopping mall is going to
save them in 2024. so forget all the
political trend lines that look abysmal
for the Democrats get everyone on the
same page tell the country that voting
Republican means essentially that you're
voting for Osama Bin Laden's relatives
Democrats have to recognize that they're
actually in war there's no Republican
party it is a dime store Front for a
terrorist organization in respect the
freedom to send your children to school
without fear of Slaughter they don't
respect the freedom of a rape victim to
be able to decide whether or not he
wants to carry a pregnancy caused by a
rapist to term they don't want Books
banned
um this is our culture War the language
of War that's such an interesting way to
put it we have to stop pretending that
Republicans are anything other than
terrorists that's not hyperbole at this
particular point they endorse terrorism
now is this their plan their actual plan
vote Democrat because the other guys are
terrorists well sure looks like it and
if you think theirs is some Noble
Mission about Universal background
checks and AR-15s then you're just too
sweet and naive to follow politics
their anti-amendment Crusade is now and
always has been about raw power
disarming the public is critical to
preserving power no matter how
tyrannical any country's leadership gets
now we know all the globalists that
organizations like the world economic
Forum they look down on our constitution
with total disgust they really hate the
fact that our Founders spelled out our
right to keep and bear arms don't like
that
and because Democrats are in lockstep
with Klaus and the Gang they're going to
work any angle to try to convince voters
that less freedom is the only way to
keep Americans safe
now notice how fast they moved on the
motive of that mall shooter in Allen
Texas police are saying the shooter was
a 33 year old man who may have consumed
Neo-Nazi and white supremacist content
online possible white supremacists going
to to malls to Gun Down other people I
mean this is there is a sickness in the
state of Texas he gravitates towards
Nazi ideology he gravitates towards
white supremacy that is a clear Embrace
of authoritarian and white supremacist
politics even if it is carried out by
people who do not appear conventionally
white
okay
so someone named Mauricio Garcia whose
family speaks Spanish at home might not
seem like the most logical Neo-Nazi to
you but we want you to see where this
investigation leads we all want to see
what the investigation leads
now the media poured over Garcia's
social media post quickly to determine a
possible motivation springing into
action scouring for every detail like
tonight's Washington Post Texas gunman
fantasized over race Wars on social
media before Mass killing
now contrast that with authorities and
the media's handling of the transgender
Mass shooter at the Covenant Christian
school in Nashville
one of the last things the post wrote
about Audrey Hale's background was the
following Nashville's shooter was
hard-working anti-social in college
Audrey Hale shot and killed six people
including three children and she left
behind a road map we know that as to why
in a Manifesto and laptops 30 journals
and other documents yet still exactly
six weeks later authorities haven't
commented on the motive instead they're
stonewalling we need to know what was
behind the shooter's motive so we can
stop it and not have it happen again it
needs to be released the people of
Nashville want to see it we need to see
it we have a right to see it
so why the refusal to tell us why Audrey
Hale was so hell-bent on killing
I'll tell you why because Democrats
think her story might hurt them
politically
yeah it's that twisted
now this is the same reason why you
rarely see Democrats run to the cameras
to talk about the black on black crime
plaguing the people of Chicago
not likely that Benjamin cromp will show
up for a 24 year old off-duty police
officer Ariana Preston
she was murdered Saturday after
finishing her shift just steps from her
door where she lived with her mom
five people including three teenagers
are in custody on armed robbery charges
as police investigate it's heartbreaking
it's infuriating
it's infuriating because the party that
gave us defund the police the summer of
riots and destruction and open border
weed legalization and lockdowns now feel
like they have the wind at their backs
because of mass shootings
the only thing Democrats have created is
chaos and economic collapse
you might not be able to afford to put
gas in your car you may not have much
savings left due to the High Cost of
Living and you may have mixed your
summer vacation plans altogether but
they think they deserve to stay in power
because they'll magically save you from
Mass Shooters with some type of gun bans
what a joke
now many major polls taken in the past
year show that inflation and the economy
are the top concerns for most voters
according to Pew's survey just last
month only 19 percent of adults believe
the economy is good or excellent 19 who
are those 19 now that includes only 28
percent of Democrats by the way
a depressing 46 percent of the public
say they expect economic conditions to
worsen in the next year while 36 percent
say it's going to stay the same only 17
percent think the economy will improve
they're in la la land
but you see why Democrats want to talk
about guns anything anything to avoid
the subject on everybody's mind
people are getting poorer as the bidens
somehow are getting richer
so without Obama hope and change they're
out
pessimism and blame are in
now both Democrats and Republicans are
less likely to express at least some
confidence in the country's future than
they were a year ago the share of
Democrats saying this has dropped eight
percentage points while the share
Republicans have dropped three points
over the same period
so as a result Biden's approval is at an
all-time low according to the new ABC
Washington Post poll just released
yesterday
and he's losing to both Trump and
DeSantis more on that in the next
segment I'll dig into all of that
now one little tidbit that shows us how
bad things are getting for the Baby
Boomers by the way the Baby Boomers who
got us into this mess almost half of
them have no money saved for retirement
half okay how is that going to play out
answer not well
so over the next 18 months you should
expect the Democrats to grow
increasingly desperate
the economy is not going to improve the
country will be flooded with illegals
and drug dealers and other criminals our
homelessness problem that's plaguing
every city and now increasingly suburbs
is going to Skyrocket it's all on the
Democrats
but they're capable of anything in this
frenzy to stay in office yeah and that
includes limiting your speech by using
the evil actions of a mentally ill
person as a justification right-wing
extremists who are motivated by uh maybe
anti-Semitism anti-immigrant beliefs or
racist beliefs fueled with grievance and
rage with the ubiquity of uh the
availability I should say of all of this
extremist propaganda on the Internet
it's much harder to distinguish or label
extremists as a member of One individual
ideology because they seem to kind of
pick those things that they like across
multiple groups and multiple ideologies
Andrew McCabe the gift that keeps on
giving you know where this is all going
we saw what Democrats were capable of
back in 2016 even using the FBI and the
doj with Jim Comey and his handling of
the Hillary Clinton investigation they
surveilled the Trump campaign then there
was the phony Russia collusion
investigation then in 2020 we saw how
the Press covered for a mentally
declining Joe Biden and then in 2022 for
John fetterman we saw how the FBI tried
to turn concerned parents at school
board meetings into their new domestic
terrorists
we saw the government colluded with big
Tech to limit speech during covid
anything they will do anything for power
so director Ray can come on this show
and answer the angles questions anytime
any night we invite him
remember the FBI only gets its
legitimacy through the respect and
funding it gets from the people who pay
the bills so it's time to answer some
real questions Christopher
and as far as the GOP is concerned its
focus must be to restore the economy and
when it gets back into power they need
to dismantle the Deep State period
federal law enforcement doesn't exist to
try to influence how we vote
at least it's not supposed to and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else